here we go this is crisis danger the
thrill of adventure
adventurers guild finally our days of
rescuing kittens and finding lost
puppies are over
the age of adventure is upon us
roll up youngsters join the adventurous
guild today
in this time of great upbeat what
what
this storm terror threat is
storm tunnels should have put up more of
a fight
we didn't get to join in
long live the heroes
thank you
it's finally over
many trade routes have closed due to the
storm terror incident
we can cope for now without fresh fruit
and vegetables
but if the wine supply dries up we're
all doomed
i cannot imagine a world without wine
i hope they get the trade routes back up
and running soon
so storm terror's true identity is
divalent
one of the four wins
we never should have forgotten his past
sacrifice for monstat
every cloud has a silver lining
we're fortunate that our relationship
with the dragon of the east didn't sour
past the point of no return
for that
we have you to thank
and jean for her unfailing devotion
as long as we have the knights of
fevonius peace and freedom will prevail
in monstat
that catches your eye
greetings may i take your order why so
cold
i've always thought that we enjoy quite
the intimate friendship
it seems your great battle sharpened not
only your combat skills but your wit as
well
a night after my own heart
to bask in the presence of monstat's new
big hero is quite the morale boost
and that's coming from a knight
sweet talking sugar-coated captain kaya
[Music]
nonsense i speak from the heart just
looking for a quiet spot to collect my
thoughts
while all the other knights are working
hard to clean up after the battle
thinking can be an arduous task you know
believe me i'd much rather be taking out
the trash
so what you're thinking about then
the abyss order
a dragon wreaks havoc in monstat and the
acting grand master leaves the city to
combat the threat
strategically that's the perfect moment
for the abyss order to make their move
if you were the abyss order would you
squander this golden opportunity to get
to the bottom of it i decided to wait
so i waited
and watched for their next move
then came the day you made all hell
break loose in storm terror's lair
just as the hilly trolls cries sounded
from the city gates
that same day
i saw shadowy figures lurking in the
city itself
inside the city
well all the other knights were outside
fighting the enemy
as you can imagine that left the inside
of the city completely unguarded
except for me of course
and so i approached the abyss order
infiltrators for a bit of
let's call it fraternizing
through various means
i managed to gather some rather
interesting intel
the situation is this
the abyss order
they are united under a single leader
the abyss order has a leader
yes
and it was this very leader who devised
the plot to turn divalent into a weapon
of war
what exactly did you have to do to find
this out
let's just say i'm blessed with certain
linguistic powers
there's more the abyss order has a now
i'm sorry to cut this intelligence
briefing short but i do believe i spy
amber heading this way
i think she's still angry with me for my
absence from the defense effort during
the attack i'd better slip away before
she notices me
one minute i see kaya the next he
slipped away clear sign of a guilty
conscience
are you sure because that sounds like
exactly what he'd say to talk himself
out of trouble
but let's forget about him i worked
super hard today my tummy is rumbling
let's order
hi sarah one sticky honey roast please
so now the storm terror threat is behind
us what are your plans for the next step
pymon thinks it's time to leave monsta
and keep looking through the seven
nations until we find clues about her
brother
huh really
oh well i guess this is goodbye for now
hey don't feel down you'll always be a
friend of the knights of evonius and
that's the spirit remember monstat will
always welcome you
all right now let's eat before it gets
cold
that was good
no to paimon amber's recommendations are
worth the wait
of course well i don't trust myself in
the kitchen you can always trust me with
the menu
oh i almost forgot to mention
gene's waiting for you at the cathedral
it's something to do with the holy land
hamel you'd better head there now